Hey everyone, it's Mike from Order
Flows. And today I want to talk about
this is a very quick video on the Delta
Scalper and UniRenko charts. I get a lot
of questions about the Delta Scalper,
like what kind of charts work best with
it, or can I use this chart, can I use
that chart? One of the questions I had
recently was specifically about UniRenko
charts. So, I want to just shoot this
quick video and show you how it looks
with the UniRenko charts.
First, brief disclaimer, this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only. It should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision.
Futures trading contains substantial
risk and is not for every investor. An
investor can potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment. Risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's lifestyle or
financial security. Only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading. Past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results.
So, this is the results, or this is how
the Delta Scalper performed with the
default settings
on various charts on Friday, August
25th. Okay, so again, you know, this is
only one day and it's at the default
settings. Next week I'll probably not
tweak the settings, but I I know I on
which markets I I can adjust the
settings out a little bit. I said again,
you know, these are the default settings
on various markets, and it will perform
better, I think, on markets that are
more I won't say volatile, but have more
price movements. Because like, for
example, here today in the crude, okay,
really quick in the crude,
it's not much, you know, basically
you've had, you know, 40 you'll call it
45 low, 85 high, a 45 a 40 cent range,
you know, so you're not going to get
many signals on markets that are
basically moving sideways, you know, not
much movements. While
in, uh, for example,
the Dow, the mini Dow, the YM today,
this is Okay, now I I have my UniRenko
charts set at, uh, 472.
Okay, and these are the default settings
for the
Delta Scalper. But, you know, you got,
you know,
here 722 you got to sell, did it work
out? A little bit. But, what's your risk
per trade? Okay, that's the important
thing, right? Um, you know, everyone
always says, "Oh, you got to, you know,
have tight stops."
Or, uh, sorry, um, you know, risk to
reward ratio, you know, two to one,
three to one, four to one, etc. But, you
know, people sometimes don't understand
really how that works. And what I'm I'm
going to show you, cuz they think that
every trade they're going to take is
going to be a winner. Well, if you got a
risk to reward ratio of four to one, you
know, even if you have, you know, 35%
winners, you're still going to come
ahead. But, you know, people like to be
consistently reinforced with winning
trades, you know, even though they they
they strive for a high risk reward
ratio, but then when they start having,
you know, um, you know, say they got a
10 to one risk reward ratio and they
have five losers in a row, they give up,
you know, which is stupid.
But,
I'll slip like here, say you're getting
short at 130, you know, you have a stop
up here at, I don't know, 410, uh, uh,
sorry, 840. So, maybe you got a 10 tick
stop, okay? So,
you know, maybe you get a little bit,
you know, a winner here, I don't know,
something out of it just goes sideways,
because then you get the the the buy,
you know, you're getting long here at,
uh, you know, 832, you know, your your
stop's down here, somewhere down in
here, around the zone. And again, you
get a nice move from
you know, what is that? 830 all the way
up to 8 880 up in here. Before it starts
going sideways, comes back down. Again,
nothing in the Delta Scalper there.
Gives you these little moves here that
aren't happening, you know, not much
happening. Um, but then the sell off.
So, say you got one losing trade, two
losing trades. We'll just say call these
losing trades here, okay? Two here. This
one, I'll say that to me that's break
even. So, you have two losing trades of,
you know, I don't know, 10 ticks. But,
then, you know, you got
30 to 80, you had one winner here of 50
ticks. So, you know, you had
four trades, one scratch, two losers,
one winner. But, your one winner more
than makes up for all your losers.
Um, you know, but, you know, sometimes
people, you know, can get lost in that,
you know, no one peop- people like to be
reinforced, right? They like to know
that,
um, you know, their method of trading
produces a lot of winners.
But, you know, they they fail to take
into account the risk to reward ratio
often times. Now,
you know, for example, E-mini S&P's,
okay? Kind of quiet, I won't say quiet
today, but, uh,
you know, it's it's a 10 point range for
the most part, roughly, just, you know,
but was there signals early? No. But,
you know, you had a nice buy here, a
nice sell here.
This is that's on the, uh,
again, default settings,
711252.
And on the, uh, UniRenko it's 472. This
is this is these are all my charts, the
same settings. Again, I'm I'm not trying
to
uh, what do you call it?
Optimize it or anything. I'm just
showing you the same same settings,
different markets. Nasdaq.
Okay, this Nasdaq, you know, you got
some nice moves today here in the
Nasdaq. Okay, so let's go back to
around, you know, 830 here.
830 is the cash open, that's when you
get the most liquidity. I mean, yeah,
there were some signals here that
failed, but, you know, that's 4:00 in
the morning, 5:00 in the morning. Really
Nasdaq is Nasdaq and Dow, you're best
trading that during the US hours.
So, it struggles here.
Loser, loser,
loser, loser, loser.
So, you what is that? Already five
losers.
Uh, loser, loser, five, six, seven.
Okay, then here, what do you got here?
58 64.
So, you got, you know, what was that?
Six losers, six, seven losers. And what
are you risking per tick, uh, per trade?
You know, say you're getting short, I
don't know, call it 64, your stop's up
here at 67.
So, you just had seven losing trades.
That's three points. Now, you get a
signal up here at 64,
all right, to get short.
What does it do? It sells off. 64 all
the way down to where
Again,
you're not getting any buy signals. Now,
whether you want to cover it here, you
know, anywhere in here is up to you, but
again, it's still giving you the short
signal.
So, say you covered it your next buy
signal, it's down here, 58.
58, uh,
what is that? 25-ish area.
So, if
64 to 25,
that's 39 points. So, you just had seven
losing trades, okay, in a row. Seven.
Then you got a trade that's giving you
39 points. So, seven times if you're
risking three points a trade, you just
lost 21 points and you're thinking,
"Shit, trading sucks, Delta Scalper
sucks. [__] Mike, I'm going to come
over there and stab you in the neck,
because I just had seven losing trades."
Well, okay, did you catch this trade?
You know, from 64 all the way down to
down into the 20's.
You know, down in here where you got
your next buy signal. I mean, I don't
know, maybe you covered it, maybe you
covered it in here, maybe you covered it
down here. You know, you got another
sell signal here, which also worked out.
Then you got this buy signal, which also
worked out. Again, you know, say you're
you're buying it in here,
is there any reason to be getting out
yet? No.
You know, so you you got, you know,
you're buying it at 25,
you know, your sell signal's up here at
35. So, that's another 10 points. So,
you know, you got a winner of 49 point
39 plus another 10, that's 49 already.
I don't know if you you know, say you
just broke even on this trade, okay?
So, you you're talking about 50 points,
you know, you lost 20 points, 21 points,
you got back 49 points. You know, that
that's what you
are supposed to do as a trader, right?
Minimize
your losing trades, get out of your
losing trades,
and let your winners run.
Um, Euro currency. I don't remember how
I did on the Euro currency. Same
settings. You know, Nasdaq it's four,
you can see 472 711252
472 71152. All these charts are the
same.
Okay, so early on in the session,
and
fail, you know, this is a small winner,
maybe a small winner here, break even
here. And then you get the nice move.
Yeah, I don't know what that is. 117.
I don't know, call it 96 all the way up
to, you know, 118
30 something.
Uh, then you have another trade. So, you
got, you know, call it losing, loser,
loser, loser, and then boom, you get a
nice winning trade.
Yeah, then you're sort of stuck with,
uh, again, some some losing trades in
here. Again, maybe if you're trailing
your stop, you can get something out of
this trade here.
Then again, you know, losing trade,
losing trade, losing trade. Then you get
a nice winner here. I'll say nice
winner, but decent one, you know, 10
ticks, 10 full ticks.
And then again, boom, another nice
winning trade up here from, I don't know
how many ticks that is.
A losing trade, and then another nice
winning trade. You know, people
sometimes they just give up on on stuff,
you know, after a couple losers in a
row. Again, another nice trade,
118 90 all the way up to 119 20. That's
another 30 points right there. I mean, I
I don't know, I'm not adding it up right
now, I'm just eyeballing it. Um, you
know, 2:00 Friday afternoon, you should
really stop trading the Euro currency
when the cash closes, but, um
I don't know if there's any decent moves
here. Yeah, not really. You know, if
you're to take the sum of all these
after 2:00, that's probably a small put
you ahead a little bit.
Now, I'm going to show you the DAX,
right? And the reason why I You know,
you got to read the disclaimers because,
you know, the DAX is a market that
well, you get on a move
you're positioned correctly on a move,
you know, it's it's you could just
[__] make bank.
Um but you got to get out when it's
going against you, okay? The reason is
why I read the disclaimers cuz sometimes
people see these DAX charts in
dollar signs or sorry, euro signs
flashing their eyes.
But look at this, okay? You get a small
move here, okay? This one fails.
Fail.
Then you get a nice move here.
235 right off the low.
Again,
is there any reason to get out at this
point? No, you got a buy signal, which
again, you know, say you got out
somewhere in here, you get another buy
here. So, you're talking, you know, from
135 all the way up to the sell, you
know, that's 30 points right there.
This one fails, but then it comes right
back with you know, that's
you know, that's up off the low. This
one fails.
It'd be nice to catch the rest of this
move. Um but then you get another signal
up here. Again, from I don't know what
that is. 200 up to the the the 215 area
where you get some start getting some
sell signals.
And it kind of goes sideways. Small
wins, small wins. And then here, you're
getting short around the 210 area.
You know, it comes down in here.
You know, I don't know what that is. 195
where it starts rallying back up. This
one fails. This one kind of fails.
This is a nice little winner. This one,
you know, I don't know. It depends how
good a trader you are. Probably would
have just broken even or something,
maybe small loss.
Same. Broken even, small loss. Nice
little trade here.
Losing trade here.
Um nice winning trade here. Maybe
something out of this, break even. Maybe
break even on this. A small winning
trade there followed by a loss.
Get short here.
Covered here. This one fails. Get long
here.
Get short here. So, you got a little
something out here. But then again,
again, you're getting short here around
the 185 86 area.
You know, and it where does it trade
down to? Trades down into the 70s. So,
we're coming back up here. And a little
buy here.
You know, it struggles. Maybe break
even.
Um where are you? You're there.
Buy here, maybe break even. Then here,
boom. Nice move from, you know, the 170
I don't know what that is. 73 area all
the way up into the 200s.
Later, you know, fail, fail. Oh, no,
this one doesn't fail. This is a little
winner. And this is another winner. So,
you could see, you know, different
markets
same settings
risk reward. Think about your risk
reward. You know, have tight stops.
Position yourself.
And you know, when you're I say position
yourself, you know, you you get into the
trade. And if it's not working out, you
get out faster. That that's it. Simple.
You know, that's why we're able to draw
these zones so you know where you should
be getting out at.
Okay?
Um again, it's not rocket science. This
is not rocket science, but you got to
understand
some of the science of trading, right?
Know when a trade is not working out and
and get out. Simple. I mean, I I can't
stress that enough. I mean, and that
that's something that, you know,
everybody who talks about, but
very few people do. You know, they'll
say, "Ah, I'll give it a little more
time to come around and and work out."
But more often than not, it just doesn't
work out.
So, get out when the trade's going wrong
and let your winners ride. You know, I
mean, [__] man. Say you just You know,
you got this trade here, you know,
again, from 175
all the way up to 200, starts turning
down. Okay, so you get out at 195. Fine.
That's 20 ticks right there.
You know, you have these trades here.
You get long here at 180. It's not
working out. Comes back down to,
you know, I don't know what that is.
Come on.
So, say you're getting long here. I
don't know. Okay, we'll call it We'll
say 181.
Okay?
Your stop is just down here at, you
know,
call it 75. So, that's a six-tick stop.
Okay? Are you willing to risk six ticks
to get you know, from 73 up to, you
know, I don't know, 200?
You know, that's 25 ticks right there.
You know, are you willing to risk the
six ticks? Risks You know, you're
getting long here, call it 70s. I don't
know. We'll say We'll say just say 78.
Okay? 78. Yeah, your stop six ticks
away.
You know, that's 72.
Are you willing to risk the six ticks
there? You get a move up to 82.
So,
it's not the greatest trade, but you got
something out of it. Again, are you
willing to you know, get short at 80
with a stop up here at 85?
You know, you're risking five ticks. And
what do you get out of this trade? From
80, you know, down into, you know, 65.
That's 15 ticks. You risked five ticks
for 15 ticks. You know, that's what you
want as a trader. You want good risk
reward ratios.
Okay, so thanks for watching this video.
Um to learn more about the Delta Scalper
and order flow, go to orderflows.com or
visit deltascalper.com. Thanks and have
a good weekend, everyone. Bye-bye.